Elon Musk has been a whirlwind in the
last couple of weeks it's very hard to
keep up with him
last night Elon Musk said that he might
step down as CEO of Twitter he would let
the people decide he said he would abide
by the results of a poll should he
remain at the head of Twitter and the
the poll said he should not remain at
the head of Twitter which is horrible I
wish Elon Musk would remain at the head
of Twitter because he's done a very good
job but this popular appeal
follows a lot of other popular appeals
that Elon Musk has made Elon Musk just a
few nights ago when I was on the Tim
pool show out in the middle of the woods
outside Washington Elon Musk banned a
bunch of liberal journalists which I
thought was awesome Tim broke the news
to me on the show I said this is great
I'm so happy and then
Elon reversed it and unbanned them
the journalists quote unquote
journalists they're just liberal
activists had been doxing Elon Musk
putting his family at risk so he banned
them but then he said okay I'll abide by
the results of the poll if
you think I should unban them they only
have a seven day suspension but I'll
unban them if you want me to and then
the people said unban them and then he
unbanned them He restored the accounts
of CNN's Donnie O'Sullivan New York
Times Tech reporter Ryan Mack wapa
reporter Drew Harwell Aaron rupparo one
of the worst of the worst Nationals Matt
binder Bender he was also allowed back
and and the principle that Elon has
articulated during this whole thing is
four words
works properly Vox day the voice of the
people is the voice of God he's used
that phrase specifically
vox populi Vox day and it's a cute
phrase and it's been used a lot
especially in the last 300 or so years
but the thing we got to remember is
it's not true
in fact the earliest appearance of the
phrase
is from a deacon named El Queen who
wrote this at the end of the 8th Century
I think it was 798 or thereabouts wrote
it in a warning to Charlemagne and he
said you got to resist this idea this is
a terrible dangerous idea he said those
people should not be listened to who
keep saying the voice of the people is
the voice of God since the riotousness
of the crowd is always very close to
Madness now the problem is
the the phrase which was initially used
to mock the idea that the voice of the
people is the voice of God later on in
the 14th century and especially after
the early 18th century came to be used
to affirm the principle that the voice
of the people is the voice of God we
even we conservatives in America
sometimes appeal to this idea when we're
feeling particularly populist and
Democratic
but it is not true more often than not
it is the opposite of true do you
remember what the mob did to Socrates
it's Christmas time do you remember what
the mob did to our Lord Jesus Christ
remember was that the voice of the
people being the voice of God
furthermore when you recognize that God
has two distinct Wills God's perfect
will and God's permissive will God's
perfect will being what God
really wants for all of us and God's
permissive will it within the context of
human Free Will turning bad things to
good this is when we say the fall of Man
in a way can be viewed as a good thing
it was bad in and of itself but a happy
fault that one for us so great So
Glorious a redeemer uh God the Father
allowing the uh passion and crucifixion
of his son Jesus
bad thing in itself
certainly seems very bad and wicked and
unjust and evil except that God has
overcome the evil of this world
that the darkness has not overcome the
light and so three days after the
crucifixion on the third day Christ
rises again conquers death and uh now
now we all celebrated Easter so when you
recognize that there's a difference
between those two things then the voice
of the people can advocate for very
wicked things indeed
it's not a conservative idea to to say
vox populi Vox day
Elon Musk though as a kind of agent of
chaos allowed this principle and then
when he reinstated the journalists the
journals go into a Twitter chat and they
all start whining about Elon Musk and
then Elon Musk joins the Twitter chat
and gives them a piece of his mind
as I'm sure everyone who's been
dachshund uh would agree you know
showing real-time information about
somebody's location is inappropriate and
I think everyone on this poll would not
like that to be known for them and and
there's not going to be any distinction
in the future between journalists
they're both journalists and and regular
people everyone's going to be treated
the same they're not special because
you're a journalist there's you're just
you're a Twitter you're just you're a
citizen
um so uh no special treatment
um a few docs you docs you get suspended
and a story
you're not that special journals I know
this is the the worst phrase you've ever
heard in your life because you believe
you work at CNN you work at MSNBC you
tell yourself
you are the fourth estate the Intrepid
courageous reporter speaking truth to
power
they're not of course they are doing the
bidding of power the most powerful
interests in the whole country are
paying their bills they say we're so
special we're standing up
and Elon says you're not special but I
have a blue check mark and now everybody
gets a blue check mark no I'm special
You Can't Ban me Elon yes I can you dox
me you docks my family
[Music]
I'm going to ban you I wish he had
banned them more
it was a good thing my only complaint
about the Elon Musk incident
is that he did not ban them more I'll be
speaking on this more a little bit later
today at TP USA I'm flying out to
Phoenix right after my show uh to
America Fest very very excited that I
was able to to make it to that so so we
will not be having a member segment
today we got great member segment coming
the rest of the week but I had to fly
out there had to go celebrate some of
the wins that we're getting right now
and had to make my plea before the
people to say no we need Elon we need
Elon to ban more of the liberal
journalists it's actually a great thing
but the the liberal journals the fence
sitters the the so-called moderates and
centrists and I don't think they're
really all that moderate or Centrist
they don't really get it Barry Weiss
who has who who is a liberal she's a
liberal journalist but because she has
in any way uh broken ranks with the far
left the conservatives all go Gaga they
say wow she's one of us I don't I don't
think she's one of us I'd like some of
her work but I'm sure we all share very
different premises about the world and
Barry Weiss lets that be known every
once in a while so Elon Musk gave the
Twitter files to expose the corruption
at Twitter under the previous ownership
two berry wise and and the other
journalist Matt taibi similar kind of
cloth you know lit liberal journalist
who sometimes breaks ranks but Barry
Weiss went off on Elon about this she
said
the old regime at Twitter governed by
its own whims and biases and it sure
looks like the new regime has the same
problem I oppose it in both cases
and I think those journalists who are
reporting on a story of public
importance should be reinstated
nope
no no that isn't true though there are
many people who would even call
themselves conservatives who agree with
Barry Weiss's point but nevertheless
it's wrong I I had this debate on Tim
cast the other night it was mostly a
debate between me and Luke on the show
Luke representing much more of the
libertarian position I was representing
much more at the conservative position
the libertarian position and the liberal
Barry Weiss position is this
anytime
anyone wields power within the Public
Square to set standards and norms and to
censor I know we're not allowed to use
the c word to censor a certain speech
that is always equally bad no matter
who's doing it
we shouldn't tolerate it
now this is a utopian and Preposterous
position because we all agree that
certain things should be banned from the
Public Square we all agree child
pornography should be banned from the
Public Square we all agree well I think
we all agree that threats should be
banned fraud should be I think we all
agree on that
all none of that type of speech has has
ever been considered protected by the
first amendment obscenity should
obscenity be banned I certainly think so
according to the laws on our books
obscenity should be banned but in recent
years legal protections
for the community against obscenity have
broken down because of activist judges
but
I think that should be banned we all
agree certain things should be censored
how about the n-word
that's a good example of a taboo in our
culture should do we think that the
n-word should be permitted and used all
over social media no one really thinks
that and and it wouldn't be tolerated
okay now what about
when we start getting into
more controversial issues
what about let's talk about uh
transgenderism
according to the old regime at Twitter
you were not allowed to call a man who
thinks that he's a woman a man that
could get you banned that was called
misgendering if you referred to Richard
Levine who's the man who wears the skirt
and he he's the assistant Health
secretary because we're living in clown
world if you refer to him as Richard or
he that could have gotten you banned
under the old Twitter regime
now today if you dox Elon Musk and his
family
that could get you banned under the new
Twitter regime I guess as a matter of
procedure
there's a similarity because certain
speech can get you banned but that's
where the similarities end okay those
are completely different uses of speech
and it is it is not the same thing
to to say we will ban you for telling
the truth
and and stating an important fact namely
that men who pretend to be women are
actually men
versus we're going to ban you for
endangering a man's life and behaving
and I would go further than that I think
there's plenty of speech that we can
police and discourage that has always
been true yeah politically political
correctness is a speech code
so is chivalry
so is being a gentleman okay it's not
the same well
if we wield political power why then
we'll be the same as the Liberals
no we won't
because while there can be similarities
with process and procedure similarities
in substance matter too I was having
this debate on timcast
if you Michael if you
encourage good things
and ban bad things
why then you're no different from the
left which is which encourages bad
things and bans good things no good and
bad are not the same
but Michael the leftists think that
they're right right but they're wrong
but how do you know what's right and
wrong because we just do that's what
ultimately this debate on Tim Cass broke
down to is I asked Luke I said Luke you
telling me we can't know the difference
between good and bad right and wrong he
says no we can't it's just arbitrary I
said okay
do you think
do you think it's better to bake a pie
for a widow or to kick a baby in the
head
and which is and he said oh I'm not
answering that's a ridiculous question
it's not a ridiculous question it's a
very simple that's a hypothetical lease
it's not a hypothetical I'm not asking a
hypothetical question which relies on
conditional statements I'm asking him a
question in the present in the Here and
Now is it better to bake a pie for a
widow or to kick a baby in the head
we all know that it's better to kick the
bit no I'm joking we all know it's
better to bake the pie for the Widow so
if we all know that then that means that
we can come to certain conclusions about
what is good and what is bad and we can
act on those conclusions that's what
self-government is
[Music]
[Music]